Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. And
I hate that this is going on, but the anti
vaccine crowd, the the covid anti vaccine
crowd is getting very belligerent and starting
to adopt more and more violent rhetoric.
Here is an anti vaccine guy who's been calling
me for a couple of weeks and he's getting
more and more fired up.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, Sarah from Mass again,
I just wanted to ask you, you must have some
really good lawyers backing you up because
you are saying and the advice you given nonmedical
about an experimental vaccine.
Speaker 1: Remember, I give no advice that
I come up with on this program.
I state what medical authorities and public
health experts say, much like Joe Biden didn't
decide, masks can come off outdoors.
Joe Biden accepts the expertize of the CDC.
So there's been no original vaccine claims
made on this program.
I think it's important to point out and a
lot of people don't seem to understand that
I'm not coming up with this stuff on my own.
Speaker 2: I mean, you can get in some serious
trouble if someone blames you or something.
There's a lot of crazy people out there.
Speaker 1: Obviously, I couldn't.
But I understand the thinly veiled threat.
Thank you.
Speaker 2: And they're going to listen to
stupid advice and the things you're saying
about getting kids vaccine with a non FDA
approved experimental vaccine.
What, are you crazy?
Right.
Speaker 1: So this is what we are up against.
If we are going to lose the fight against
the pandemic, we have the tools.
If we were vaccinating four million a day
right now instead of two million a day, which
now is limited only by lack of interest, the
U.S., you know, there's countries desperate
for supply.
We have the supply.
We have we have a lack of of enough interest.
So vaccinations have been declining.
We could be far closer to ending this thing
if it weren't for the point of view of people
like this guy.
So that's extraordinarily dangerous that the
rhetoric is getting more violent.
And I don't know what the outcome is going
to be, but that is some really scary stuff.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about the Florida de
platforming law and its constitutionality.
Very interesting issue that relates to free
speech.
It relates to digital freedom and so much
more.
We are also going to talk about increasingly
those who is going to suffer in the future
from the lack of attention to the climate
crisis today.
Well, it's those who are now children and
children are increasingly taking governments
to court over climate and they're starting
to win.
They are starting to win.
And we will talk about that.
And lastly, is it time for the FDA to ban
all menthol cigarets?
Some of you would say all cigarets should
be banned, but we are specifically going to
talk about what's going on with menthol cigarets
on the bonus show today.
I had no idea.
That this was a source of such controversy,
controversy, controversy and concern among
the medical community, all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show, Memorial Day,
a very special day.
We will be off.
There will be no show on Memorial Day.
It'll be a perfect holiday.
But we will we will also be doing a single
day membership special one day.
Huge ungodly discount.
Haven't done this for months and months.
If you would like to be notified of that membership
special on May 31st, it's as simple as going
to my website and signing up for my newsletter.
That is it, my friends.
That is it.
I will see you on the bonus show momentarily.